A lichen actually consists of two organisms:
A fungus, and alga or cyanobacteria
or so we thought for 140 years.
In lichen, the fungus provides a home
while the algae provides nutrients
together they form the unusual structures
that grow on the surfaces of
rocks and trees
Lichens break down the rocks into soil,
take up pollutants from the air and live
in places most other organisms avoid
It's hard to do genetics in lichen
they grow slowly,  bind themselves tightly
to their substrates and when they are
sequenced
yield a mismash of DNA from two organisms.
Take these two related lichens:
they're different colors and one makes a toxin.
Looking at both the fungus and the algae gene activity
in the two lichens
researchers saw no differences
But when they looked at the activity of all the genes
they discovered a yeast was also part of these lichens
So the twosome was actually a threesome
These yeast genes were more active in one of the lichens
possibly explaining the difference in color
To prove the yeast really there
the researchers labeled each of the
lichen's organisms
with fluorescent tags
They discovered that the yeast
coat the outer wall of the fungal hairs
and are surrounded by toxic acidic
crystals
The algae line the inside of the wall
They found the yeast in many other lichen--on different continents
suggesting that this is a widespread three-way partnership
gone undiscovered for over a 140 years